welcome to the yearly let's complain
about you to rewind 2019 edition I have
returned from exile Thank You YouTube
gods I exist now after two years of
being excluded in YouTube rewind and
complaining about it every possibly have
I am finally in YouTube rewind this is
so awesome
everyone is gonna love YouTube rewind
now that I am in it oh no oh God
despite YouTube's best efforts YouTube
rewind is still a disaster this is so
sad FS in the chat they actually showed
me this rewind before I actually got to
see it and I got to give feedback on it
and they took some of my feedback but it
still bummed listen it's not my job to
create this video they just showed me
the finalized product okay this is not
how I would do it okay if I can control
rewind we'll get into how I would make
it regardless I do find it kind of funny
cuz it's almost like they try to avoid
all the politics that went on in the
previous ones of who they're gonna put
up there and who they're gonna celebrate
and what things are gonna celebrate and
they just said okay we'll just show the
top ones and then that way you can't
complain and I just completely backfired
and when I saw it I'm like oh that makes
sense actually
this way they avoid everyone complaining
about it cuz it's just the list
you can't complain by list this is
democracy this is what you said you like
this videos not does it's not our fault
yeah I actually have a lot of thoughts
on this we'll get into it I wasn't
planning to make a video on this because
just like everyone when you watch it the
reaction is this yet there's not much to
say about it it's kind of boring it's a
wash mode your video that's what
everyone's sentiment is when they react
to YouTube rewind but I thought let's go
through it anyway and I can get my
thoughts on it because that's the yearly
tradition of this channel
I find it funny that people thought this
is like a preview of rewind Hoover
didn't even realize it was the actual
rewind that is so awkward to watch that
bad word that's the first words I love
ITA's cringe answer so good okay don't
start with Casey Neistat I'm sorry I
like Casey nice that don't get me wrong
but he's been in every rewind ever at
this point and also him yelling kpop as
funny as it is that was not the cringe
is part of rewind okay it was will
submit going yeah if I got to control
rewind I would get get back will submit
and recreate that beautiful moment where
he goes yeah that would have been cool I
would have liked that Marquez did a
video with Will Smith even and made him
react to that meme I thought it was so
gay good times and I brought you down
with me or this way obviously it's gonna
be hard to get people involved with
rewind now like no one wants to touch it
anymore
this curse object so I'm already going
off tangents that is so awkward to watch
YouTube rewind 2018 the most disliked
video in history on you it's it really
damn I didn't realize and 2018 we made
something you didn't like so into a
nineteen let's see what you didn't like
because you're better at this than we
are I know they didn't mean for this but
it does come across as a tiny bit
passive aggressive riding wording it
that way listen maybe if I was hired I
could have given better feedback all
right
I hate this click for the shoe it pisses
me off every time I don't know why I
think it's a cool concept though of
showing just the top ones I know
everyone hated it because it's like oh I
can just look that up but when I watched
through it I was actually surprised when
I saw some of the top videos I'm like oh
really damn we'll get to that I guess I
have no idea without the Jewess the most
like crater videos I don't know this
thing I don't know what to say about
this is there's nothing to reacting
that's why I didn't want to make the
initial ad I'm like I don't know hey
look at that the mainstream and I think
this video I think mr. Bies deserves to
be number one he had an amazing year
obviously but you know the title is make
this video the most liked video on
YouTube the whole goal of this video
this is not me being salty but I'm being
number one but the whole point of this
is to get that metric you know so it
kind of fits the whole purpose of you
made this the most liked video well it
doesn't give a genuine reflection of
what the year is that's my point right
it doesn't capture the moments of what
happened last year and I feel like
that's the whole problem with this they
try to avoid the politics which makes
sense but then you lose the reflection
of what the year it was and I think this
is a good example of that I don't care
about music videos I'm just gonna move
on most like dance videos
there's video games hey roblox is
apparently huge Jesus Christ what is
this game get on the free fire had 30
billion views what what this is like a
fortnight pub G clone and it has 30
billion views I've never heard of it
almost more than GTA Jesus Christ
[Music]
Minecraft's hundred billion baby goddamn
goddamn that's nuts
you know I always avoid the top games
like my I used to avoid minecraft and I
don't like fortnight because it's just
so lame guess mine crafting sort of
became cool again but still alright most
like beauty videos I guess they have to
have this cool I don't care let's move
on these new creator breakouts it's good
that they had this because obviously if
you're just with this topless format
you're just gonna get money the top
graders are gonna get monopoly and
that's not fair either industry plant
I'm just kidding
Oh through Gordon made it in that's
awesome again there's not much to say
about it and then they had the most
viewed creators as he landed two billion
what mr. B's dude perfect david dobrik
jelly two point five days an animation
channel had two point eight billion I
never even heard of that's nuts and I
honestly was shocked to see myself as
number one I didn't know four billion
brah four billion my videos aren't even
good how will people not realize this
yet then they had a celebration of of
random things like top female artists
and friends and furs middle east and
creator to hit ten million subscribers
and Carissa God said occasional yadda
yadda yadda
and you know I understand that it
doesn't really fit to put it decay in
there somewhere for those who don't know
it took it was a youtuber that passed
away last year he committed suicide he
definitely deserves to be recognized in
some way I understand that it doesn't
really fit in this format but they
should have made space for it in my
opinion I didn't even think about it
when I gave feedback to be honest but
it's still it's so obvious I find it
kind of funny because everyone's like oh
this is a WatchMojo video well jut watch
mode you've made their own rewind and
what they did was they rank the moments
that happen their personal favorite
moments and there you go there you have
an actual reflection of what happened
this year case I versus Logan and Peter
pie versus T series and look they made
space for ethic as well they've somehow
managed to do it so it isn't impossible
huh some other notes apparently
congratulations got more likes than
number eight but they didn't include it
okay so there was some politics involved
I've watched her last years as well and
oh my god it was so much worse than I
remember Jesus Christ
Oh God oh so bad and all the preachy
nests
and all the but I didn't think this year
was that bad that was my genuine
reaction I don't think it's that bad
I don't think it's that important I
don't think it's that big a deal but
clearly these videos have worked
themselves up to be something really big
for the platform it's almost like it's
become a way for people to just unleash
all their frustration with YouTube into
one spot like that's what it feels like
it's become let's read some comments as
well all the reason I watched this is to
see if they put Felix and Marcia's vet
wedding that's it last year we made
something with the most disliked so this
year let's try to break that wreck okay
all right
I feel like that'd be unnecessary hate
it's just like kind of cringe as well it
doesn't feel like our YouTube rewind to
me well no one likes YouTube rewind why
would they try and capture it but I
think that's the point people did used
to like rewinds like the 2015 one was
great people really liked it it was very
very popular
and that's crazy - looking back on these
but the problem is that along the way
these YouTube rewind videos became more
and more of an advertising reel and made
it so that we can only show that the top
friendliest creators and and look how
good we are I look how all the positive
things we come and it just becomes creep
preachy and it became cringy and it
stopped becoming a reflection of what
the year was and more just over hey look
how I look advertisers look how epic our
website this and it just became more and
more and more and more you know YouTube
probably spend millions and millions to
create these videos and that's an
investment for them to make so that they
can get more advertisers on onto the
platform but when in reality 2018 wasn't
a good year for YouTube a lotta created
who were frustrated and then shoving
this video into your face was probably
the worst thing you could possibly do so
it's like this year they just given up
on the whole advertising real thing and
you know people made the joke like what
I could have added this rewind do they
pay an intern 500 bucks or something
like that but obviously if they can't
make an advertising reel out of it why
would they spend the money on it and it
makes perfect sense from that
perspective they did engage with people
making fun of the rewind in the comments
on Twitter which I thought was funny Wow
YouTube rewind 2019 which is an upgraded
version of top 10 enemy list how are we
supposed to make me in Saturday's come
on peak 2019 mood being mad that youth
everyone didn't give enough to be so
good so true alright a couple things
Charlie pointed out I think pretty well
in his rewind oh yeah well because the
ship has already sailed people know that
YouTube is not out to make itself a
better platform for viewers or creators
they're out to make it better and safer
for brands it takes one click to figure
that out when you go to YouTube's
homepage when you're not signed in all
you get as a recommended or available to
watch right away
is Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon slapping
his [ __ ] desk and piss in his pants
and that's what we wanted to came you
know but people know that's not the
truth Jack Sims also did a good video
where he pointed out like secretly we
want the cringe we want to see Keanu
Reeves say you're breathtaking
- baby Yoda and
we all love to hate YouTube rewind at
this point let's get real here so Ethan
got an email from YouTube about
promoting rewind if I am tweeting about
YouTube rewind and I asked
I need that pose a call to action
question to my fans like what was your
favorite part of rewind hashtag YouTube
rewind and then what people respond to
me and use the hashtag they'll get a
surprise and a delight someone from
YouTube will randomly select people that
respond to me to give them way for it a
fanny pack
wait so YouTube wanted Ethan to post
what was your favorite part of rewind
and the top comments will get a fanny
pack guys what was your favorite part of
YouTube rewind 2019 fanny pack question
mark so yeah that's pretty much all my
thoughts that I had on 2019 rewind I
know not very exciting but there's not
much to work with I wonder what they
should do at this point like what can
YouTube do to have a successful rewind
cuz clearly big done it before
I think that's literally it they just
need to go back to what it used to be a
reflection of what the year is don't
exclude creators and stop showing the
same creators over and over again I
wonder if they will actually go back to
that then or not it will be interesting
to see next year what they're gonna do
clearly this new format didn't work out
well but it's still didn't do as bad as
last year so hey that's an epic win what
do you think would make the perfect
rewind I think that's it yeah good just
go back to what it used to be but then
again how are you gonna get people
involved like if I got asked to be in
rewind 2020 I'd be like oh I don't know
about this you gotta you gotta have to
prove yourself first kind of yeah
alright that's it hope you guys enjoyed
this video see you bye bye hey hey oh
actually guys make this to like the
video so next year we can be part of
rewind
for too long you have been farting in
the corner now you are entering a new
era where you shall crafts thy own poop
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne where T is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices